in 1999 a tiny little independent film
called The Blair Witch Project was
released and it went on to be that this
smash hit made 250 million dollars
worldwide it also got rave reviews even
from Roger Ebert he called an
extraordinarily effective horror film it
was actually one of the most successful
independent films ever made
writing on the success its sequel Book
of Shadows Blair Witch 2 was released
just a year later it was like
universally hated by every single critic
someone called it a club-footed vomit
launch of teen horror cliches it was bad
really bad and it got us wondering what
are the best and worst sequels of the
last 20 years so anytime you google
search a film you'll immediately be
presented with its Metacritic rating you
have all these movie critics all around
the United States and they all use these
different systems to review movies
Metacritic normalizes these rankings on
a 1 to 100 scale putting more weight on
critics with more clout Zachary my
colleague here was given a dataset of
13,000 films for Metacritic and found
every movie with a sequel since 1996
that's 532 films total we wanted to know
like what are the movies that did really
really really well the first time around
and then just totally tanked the second
time around in other words the biggest
disappointments that's where films like
Book of Shadows Blair Witch 2 comes in
so the original got a score of 81 points
the sequel got a score 15 points that's
66 points less or take Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon
the first Mandarin language film
nominated for Best Picture it went on to
win Best Foreign Language Film well 16
years later Netflix released a sequel in
English the original got a score of 93
the sequel so unfortunately it fared
much worse
too much blazing flame it got 47 so on
the flip side you have films that did
really poorly the first time around and
somehow miraculously did better when
they were made into a sequel this is
like a really small contingent of all
the sequels we looked at less than 25 of
the 532 films were improvements outside
of movies like The Dark Knight in Kill
Bill Vol - most of these movies were
tremendously bad to begin with
like for instance Garfield's Part 1 got
a score of 27 your mind to it it's not
that hard to improve on that like
Garfield part 2 got 37 which is still
pretty bad yeah not bad on short notice
the worst ones fall into like one of
three categories it's either a horror
film a comedy film or an action film so
I wanted to see is that just a bigger
indication of what how critics raid
those movies what I did is like I looked
at a randomized selection of 200 films
from every single genre on Metacritic
and then averaged out the score for each
genre this chart reveals that the genres
with the worst sequels also fare pretty
badly amongst critics in general despite
all of this Hollywood loves making them
so much so that this year alone an
unprecedented 37 sequels will be
released
the reason money the average sequel
makes eight times the average original
release that's a hundred and sixty
million dollars over the twenty million
dollar original grown-up's the Adam
Sandler movie which was rated an abysmal
30 points on Metacritic received 270
million dollars worldwide its sequel
which somehow dropped 11 points still
managed 247 million dollars worldwide it
was a box-office hit
audiences literally had no reason to
give grownups too a chance and yet they
did Roger Ebert famously said no movie
executive was fired because he greenlit
a sequel but movie critics despair of
sequels as betraying a lack of
imagination in originality if you have
any doubt about how true that is
give grownups to a world
Oh bonus
you